we see a lot about your personal life on
the show Noah's on the show but things
seem complicated people who follow us
think they have a right to know
everything that's going on in our lives
the status of our relationship is
everyone should mind their own business
so set the record straight what is your
relationship status today we are
together but keeping it offline and it's
just not obviously it does make things
more complicated keeping things offline
but at the end of the day it's just
there's so much back and forth in trying
to build a career and trying to figure
out if we're even happy and the careers
were paths we're going in if this is the
thing we want to do or going from seeing
each other every day in quarantine and
then being so busy and having schedules
that we can't align together with was
very hard and very difficult and I think
I just hope people give us Grace because
we are 21 and obviously we did have the
choice of like putting it on the show
but we do have people who care about us
and people care about our relationship
and we want to share a little bit and
you can't expect us to have all the
answers of how to handle this kind of
situation properly because there's no
rule book there's no answer and like we
take it day by day instead you took your
relationship offline but it made things
more complicated I think so it
definitely just it was hard because we
obviously want to like show each other
off and like yeah all the few things and
at the same time it was just like
brought up more confused confusion and
questions oh they're together they're
not together and it's just like so much
but we just didn't know how to handle it
and we still don't we're still like
we're not even focusing on that right
now or having that discussion of like
how we're going to move forward with
like posting or if we're gonna say
anything and it's just not something
that I ever thought I would get into of
having like a public online relationship
where people would care about but it's
definitely probably one of the most
toughest part of my life my life that I
shared because at the end of the day we
both want to be our own people as well
and we never want to be Dixies boyfriend
or know his girlfriend because we want
to have our own careers and paths and we
wouldn't want to stay into the way of
like if we were to break up if like I
was trying to get a job or he was trying
to get a job and then it would be
referred to as Dixie's ex-boyfriend or
Noah's ex-girlfriend and that's just not
something either of us wanted
you look beautiful and I want to point
out this beautiful wonderful new
hairstyle that you're rocking how is
life with this shorter hair it's very
easy to just get up in the morning and
not have to do anything it's already
grown out a lot and I cut it like two
weeks ago really you already feel like
it's coming back in yeah definitely is
this something that you think you want
to keep up for a while do you like miss
the old hair are you really loving this
new style definitely want to get a few
more pictures with it and then I think
I'm gonna grow it out like not because I
don't like it I just had its time I
always wanted to do it I did it and now
on to the next you gave it its moment
for sure what is the reaction from like
your friends your fans your family
what's it been I think for the most part
everyone's been very positive about it
loves it and I'm happy with it so I
don't really that's all that matters
that's all that matters it's all you and
I I want to give you a big virtual hug
because I watched your YouTube video
documenting the whole you know hair
cutting experience like I've been like
sad recently but I don't want to say
anything because I don't want anyone to
think I'm like having a mental breakdown
I wanted to do this since like sixth
grade I mean it wasn't really connected
at all like why I'm sad and the reason
for change it's kind of like just
feeling down but not like for anything
specific just like one of those times
that you have your UPS of new down so
it's just going through downtime but I
think it was kind of something that I've
always wanted to do I would regret if I
didn't and I just didn't want people to
think like she cut her hair because
she's sad it was more like I just so
happen to be sad at the same time that I
decided to cut my hair I have to tell
you I watched that whole video and I was
so moved and empowered by it I was like
you go Dixie you do whatever makes you
feel better and gives you that
confidence and I am curious now that
you've done it are you feeling better
today yeah here and there um but
definitely more confident which I'm very
happy about amazing well I I see all of
that confidence in you as a performer
and a huge part of this season two of
the demilio show is following you and
your your wonderful music career that's
been on the uprise
[Music]
you know I think it's interesting that
you and Charlie both make comments in
the show about how you want to be taken
really seriously as musicians and as
entertainers and not just you know like
quote social media Stars so is that a
label that bothers or frustrates you not
really because I think at the end of the
day it's super cool being at the top of
something and being like one of the top
10 tick talkers like why wouldn't I
embrace that at the same time I don't
see why there's any reason someone who
started in one place can't go to another
and there's so many people I look up to
who have done things like that and made
a huge transition from social media to
music and becoming like an amazing
artist that I really would love to fall
in their footsteps one day look at
people like Shawn Mendes or Justin
Bieber and like even people who go on
like singing shows and just start on
there and then and then go on Tick Tock
and then create a fan base through the
show take talk and then through their
music I loved watching season two
because we really get to see you in the
trenches you know rehearsing for Jingle
Ball going to the studio writing music
now that it seems like your whole focus
is really shifted and you're really in
it do you think there's ever gonna come
a time when you put being an influencer
on the back burner and kind of stop
making full-time content so you can
focus on the music and being an
Entertainer I feel like it all kind of
goes together because I wouldn't have my
audience without Tick Tock and not
everyone that follows me on Twitter I'm
just gonna like my music or anything
else I do so I can't isolate that group
because I'm only focusing on one thing
if I'm posting I'm working on everything
if I'm working on music I'm posting so I
hand in hand yeah definitely now a huge
theme that we see here in season two is
that your sister Charlie also has
musical aspirations but it's kind of in
secret I don't feel ready to tell Dixie
about music because this was her thing I
don't know how she'll react to is not
telling her have you watched the
episodes back how did it feel to to live
with all of that footage like our lives
went on and I feel like people are gonna
try to make something bigger than it is
but we're sisters at the end of the day
we love each other and we are roommates
so nothing is too bad was it more that
she's entering a similar space as you or
was it more that it was just like a
secret and you're like I wish you would
have come to me as a sister and we could
have talked about this it was more of
just a secret aspect but I feel like
you'll get to be able to see more in the
show yeah and I mean there's so many
famous sisters that have made it both
the Jessica Simpson and Ashley Simpson
Beyonce and Solange Chloe and Hallie
Bailey how do you feel about Charlie
joining you in this space and you being
able to do this all together I mean I
think it's amazing I feel like we sound
very differently we are interested in
different genres and different types of
music I think it doesn't really affect
each other at all besides in positive
ways where we can support each other
yeah have those conversations and like
gut check each other like creatively I
imagine that it's no one better to talk
to than your sister
hmm
the demilio family our social media
Sensations this whole ride has been a
roller coaster welcome to season two
thank you for giving us season two of
the demilio show are you down for season
three do you want to keep sharing your
life with with your audience definitely
I have a great time doing it I just I
would love to yeah yeah is there is
there anything off limits that you you
will never put on TV for for your fans
to see I don't think so like nothing's
come up or we're like oh no don't shoot
that you're an open book
foreign